io mi chiamo gli altri con la ricca
no non l'ha nemmeno con la tappa e
nemmeno con la reputo un iniziale
scetticismo come una pizza pomodoro e
mozzarella
no non vogliate con la o indiretto
popolati iniziale dopo meno di una
stretta con la mia i no miglia con gli
occhi che ti a rho pero con la mia
carrozzina 30 anni a 100 kg e nella
passano nuova ogni mille anni f1 e sono
alcune alla prima poco perché sono
jacopo con lei e ho 25 anni
il mio passaggio più bello è stato jean
sono nato perché se non mi ricordo
niente però che è stato indiano
passaggio mi aspetto mia mi passa forse
è più oneroso il meritorio ma
sicuramente è stato il mio passaggio
inverno sono qui adesso sono qui con noi
buongiorno e non m'intendo niente
monomio però software per i miei
genitori e la mia nascita fu uno shock
fu il ponte tra il prima e il nuovo anno
che prendono e ti sbattono come un uomo
smo appunto come per ogni genitore la
nascita né ogni mio ma per loro impone
più genitori né un bambino
un disabilità
ho paura a dirlo così è una noia se
tanto mi dà ragione e non si sa o non si
conosce oppure ciò che guardiamo una
lontano perché è un modo che pur che
muore e non sapere o non conosce e
allora io sono qui stasera con voi per
presentarmi è però misurarmi farmi
conoscere le parrocchie nei freni sono
un cielo lomba chiamato pina la mia
cantina per persone di femmine ma lusso
18 ma mirano alla mia nascita
ci sono voluti quindici anni ai miei
genitori per riprendersi poi è nata mia
sorella costanza con l'affitto era
iniziato a mangiare per l'ania sprimere
alla fine una pagina facebook cambia gli
uomini l'altro a costruire ponti in un
modo o nell'altro o con la onlus muore
pane nel piano in un modo sono allora i
miei toni non si sono più canonico mia
non è in un buono nell'altro impegno
l'accessibilità con i suoni nei pressi
dei suoi phone essi in olio ponti acer
simili negozi a simili al pane e arces
rimini torchi e pinete come questo acer
rimini cinema malagnino soprattutto
voglio persone che top esempio il cane o
seduto in piani
eccone lavoro io sono fuori dal bagno
legna mica pochi con la mia carrozzina
che adesso ti aspetto così il poi dopo
kyoto per questa il maglione gli anni fa
e non è giusto che mi ha annunciato
martini non ha mica parte è
semplicemente
punito ma io sono certo scusa unanime no
continua pure a fissare in piedi e
quindi siamo in his vengano poi tutti
sono stupidi come tutti oppure sono
intelligenti sono onesti o disonesti
sono simpatici o antipatici 41 e minuto
nemmeno qualcuno è molto molto nello con
m e ironico e autoironico qualcuno e
modesto che a qualcuno mi piace la vita
ea qualcuno mi piace il trash unità mini
dicono in esame nicolò le polacche hanno
pensano che possano considerano in un
monologo come questo ventennio in italy
non sperano sempre preferito uomini non
sono sempre canestri anni se non le
tette questa netta tra il monologo ne
prende qualcuno sembra almeno mano
asportarlo che fai due palle così
qualcuno con la g ne appena ridere
eppure ti fa spanciare dal fratello
unico almeno in e spente qualcuno invece
avranno è molto molto da ridere
eppure il pres
è vero questo lo ne ho sentite anche
sopra gli uomini passano gli anni e
quindi non bisogna aspettare c'è un
aereo sia passato apple timone questo
monologo
adesso studiando a sostituire la parola
mi esamini con persone quante persone
pista su alcune persone giustissime
molte persone si alleni ma divertente
eolica marina ascoltarla ti fai due
palle così molte persone invece ci fa
pensare anche se in realtà miei motivi
per ridere non rm molti talk like hell
nei miei mostri mi dà grande tanti per
essere venire pure nm3 misto funziona lo
stesso sesso in una persona verso
manifat milita anche voi come pure per
mi esprimono uno dei più visto che può
sostituire i bustoni di sospensione con
un posto qualsiasi
io ho mai posto nemmeno ci sono stato
però non hanno visto una carrozzina non
è temi mi hanno sostituito da quella
persona in carrozzina ma io non solo la
mia carrozzina io non sono io a quello è
in carrozzina
anzi per ogni minima comodità e mutu ma
mi sa che io non sono in poi ho grande
impegno in ultimo lo metti in carrozzina
primo mi mette in ogni somiglio anche se
magari lui mm solo modo allora infami
fra tribù in ogni cane almeno questa
frase primo con lo tanina che non il
penalista milita allora in famiglia non
mi piace io mi sono rotta tornei nel
piccolo caminata mente una condizione
come quella nella disabilità e come ho
fatto io
prima per amore ma anche questo monologo
ed eccomi familismo almeno non sono i
piagnoni e non hanno tutti ragione anche
se quando tu non esamine patemi la
macchina nel posto riservato agli uomini
è vero ma non asi
hanno tutti sempre ragione o come non è
più solo il testo archita canyon e poste
in essere noti alle persone
ogni famiglia e non essere di famiglia e
l'altro no qualcuno segnerebbe la
carrozzina al posta nelle gamme montino
e no la disabilità è nata dai negozi in
assassini in altalena inaccessibili
macinano i massimi da oltre in
attrazioni rapporti una pineta come poi
è stato non propone solo una possibilità
da persone inaccessibili per questo è
contro cupo questo gli ho risposto lo
strigo lotto perché mi saranno possono
altri versi se le cose sono molto
importanti
se questa mostra in acquisti new o sette
sono molto nemmeno con la fissa nei miti
quel che sa bene una cosa che mi
piacciono forte nei testi alcuni con lo
stesso che per questo è registrato in
tante nazione per la mole l'attenzione
che mi piace e mi piacciono le cose che
da piccolo non buon inizio tra
l'ospedale di bologna rendano mangiarne
almeno questo non lo diciamo e oltre le
foto più che mandiamo le poste quello
noto unione presente e sempre nel mac
donald e non da meno è strano un male
per la pania camera con il tempo con
microfono sentite questo nell che sono è
una cosa aspetta sogno adesso se mi
chiedi mani a un controllo
io che lo sfondo mori mi prende punti
anche fa mi hanno una meta per suole che
una vita sentimentale non è né sempre
con
no non è di per sé un nemico più facile
questa è la porta è fondamentale è il
ponte e passaggio statine capirci e
anche se non chiamate con i a capirci
perché sono persone innamorate che
stanno insieme e quando l'amore persone
non innamorato però fanno tanto sesso
persone innamorata che stanno insieme
senza fare l'amore che possono persone
innamorate cercando insieme fanno un
omone l'apostata scaloni non è capitano
ecco è uno stile ma erano meno
innamorate io per te non lo so non so
risponderle ma mi hanno fatto nelle
risposte con la pensione dalla ministra
sia un buon successo per un fine
monologo e monete che cos'è e non mi
piace chi alza la moglie perché sono
convinto che le cose ingiuste mie pezzo
voce facciano molto più rumore nelle
cose sbagliate urlate mi piace nelle
grate mia non è stata io potete usarlo
fiutato che lui sa bene che coperto mi
fa paura per i capelli
lo so che avrei mille altri problemi a
cui pensare ma minieri spenti armi
venirmi premi termini fa paura perché mi
pare dal tempo che passa e linea 3 1 che
la sposa 30 40 50 anni a costruire
relazioni che poi in un attimo possano
spagna si parla parla e morte e un'altra
è pronto per inizio giugno
[Musica]
speriamo si infiamma mine sennò con
questo sogno
il napoli non mi quando una persona
venire mente chimini poi ti lascia il
posto in a mi me un altro mi piace molto
quando una ragazza anche un appuntamento
mina un memo e mi piace molto quando una
notte anche un appuntamento per tania un
tale rispetto mi da molto fastidio buone
le persone mi toccano i piani
no non è stata che i piani proprio
l'unica fellow palloni non è conscio che
sono il parroco cena ma miriamo in un
uomo è che un atto per l'inizio ma stato
quindi e poi nelle foglie rami mamma
perché sono un italiano medio
sono stato il blocco è però male poco
perché ero in fila infine tragicamente
in italia però vorrei andare lei il
furto
alcuni ne sarà il polpo mi piace
disposizione la mia sorella non rispondo
al suo io chiamo in realtà mi piacciono
sempre mia sue espressioni
non ho una sorella come costanza ripiano
zapponi tose male non fosse di almeno
tutte che parli male al mare il profumo
nel modulo fabio primi insomma mi
malpede e un po per tutti mi hanno una
potenza tra ho messo sul wall mart e non
lo trovava pedane e il 30 40 sarà un età
media 50 anni ma ho voluto sapere quante
sono
meglio stare a potenza
mi va bene ma che per vent'anni mi va
che penso
il nemico